pues este caso en realidad esta
investigación comenzó sobre el 2013 2014
porque el presidente de sarkozy estaba
bajo escucha en esa época estaban
investigando les sobre la financiación
de su campaña en el 2007 precisamente se
había recibido o no dinero por parte de
la heredera de l'oréal liliane
bettencourt y finalmente esa cruz y lo
que quería era saber cuál iba a ser el
fallo de la corte de casación
él quería saber esto gracias a un
magistrado river así ve y a cambio de
estas informaciones pues el presidente
le ayudaría a este magistrado de esta
alta corte a obtener un puesto en a
mónaco ese digamos es toda la gran parte
de este proceso de este juicio que se
terminó el día de hoy y que la fiscalía
financiera francesa pues basso la mayor
parte de su acusación precisamente en
estas escuchas telefónicas entre nicolas
sarkozy y su abogado thierry herzog en
los que se les escucha hablar
precisamente de esto de cómo obtener
estas informaciones que para el tribunal
pues
hay claramente digamos un acto de
corrupción sellado entre los tres y
efectivamente si también va a haber
apelación ya hace unos minutos se supo
que los tres van a apelar la decisión
del tribunal
natalia quienes son los otros acusados
en este caso
los otros dos no es nada más y nada
menos que tierra
abogado y amigo personal de nicolas
sarkozy además él fue pues igual recibió
la misma sentencia misma condena que
nicolas sarkozy pero además de esto en
la prohibición de ejercer el derecho por
los próximos cinco años
algo que es considerado severo pero al
mismo tiempo tienen ustedes que saber
que tiene ya dos o que es una de las
personalidades de los abogados más
importantes y más influyentes del país y
por otra parte el otro es el magistrado
si vea a cyber bueno ya ex magistrado ya
retirado magistrado de la corte de
casación una de las cortes más altas del
país
natalia este es un caso histórico para
francia porque es la primera vez que un
ex presidente comparece físicamente ante
un tribunal penal en calidad de
procesado que otros antecedentes
similares hay con otros expresidentes en
casos no tan relevantes como éste
bueno uno que generó muchísimo levantó
muchísimo escándalo fue el caso de
jacques chirac que es el otro ex
presidente francesa que tuvo que dar
cuentas ante la justicia francesa esto
fue en un caso de empleos ficticios en
la alcaldía de parís recordemos el
reaccionar fue alcalde de la capital
entre 1977 y 1995 y en este caso pues
chirac fue condenado a dos años de
prisión por estar exento de cumplimiento
y fue encontrado culpable de
malversación de fondos y también de
abuso de confianza
[Música]